l'utilisation des canons à neige s'est
généralisé au cours des dernières
décennies au québec il ya 83 % des
stations qui possède un système d'ahmed
ma mécanique un contexte de changement
climatique
l'enneigement artificiel est essentiel
pour la rentabilité de la majorité des
stations de ski
mais certains organismes s'inquiètent
des impacts à long terme sur
l'environnement qui devrait la vrille et
une surveillance un petit peu plus accru
il ya près de 15 ans anne-sophie demers
publié une étude sur les impacts
négatifs de l'enneigement artificiel au
mans fed
on voit des impacts bien au delà dans le
fond du domaine skiable
par exemple l'eau qui alimente les
canons à neige est puisée dans cet étang
situé au coeur du parc national
anne-sophie demers avait soulevé des
préoccupations quant à l'impact sur la
faune et la flore ça prend 25 % du
volume total de l'étang pour pallier
dans le fond à cet enneigement le s qui
représente quand même une bonne
proportion de cet habitat le donc ça
peut a fait menacer les communautés
ripart yen qui sont laïques sont en
dormance pendant l'hiver un autre impact
de l'enneigement artificiel c'est
l'érosion accélérée de la montagne
justement à la fonte des neiges
c'est une surcharge extrêmement
importante en eaux de ruissellement
qu'on impose à la montagne qui est cette
surcharge le dans le fond elle a des
effets très importants au niveau de tout
le réseau hydrographique dans le fond il
ya beaucoup d'érosion qui peut se créer
puis on voyait même aussi des impacts le
jusqu'au lac memphrémagog au niveau de
la sédimentation si cet impact qui
préoccupe le conseil de la gouvernance
de l'eau des bassins versants de la
rivière saint-françois lot d'humour feu
d'aboutir au ruisseau castor et se
déverse ensuite dans le lac memphrémagog
où on retrouvait la prise d'eau potable
de plusieurs municipalités entre de
magog sherbrooke et de potton c'est une
problématique des effets sera long terme
parce que c'est récurrent chaque année
donc chaque année on accumule un petit
peu plus de problèmes
c'est une première
connue mais qui méritait de s'y attarder
peut-être un petit peu plus malgré des
observations préoccupante
les ministères des parcs et de
l'environnement nous ont confirmé qu'ils
n'ont effectué aucune étude ou suivi sur
l'impact de l'enneigement artificiel a
offert ou ailleurs quant à lui le
directeur de la station de ski du mont
orford assure qu'il ya des mesures
d'atténuation pour réduire les effets
négatifs de la production de neige
l'eba viardot et le contrôle d'évasion à
mon père qui la sauverait plus important
il assure que la station ne souhaite pas
à croître à outrance sa production de
neige dans les prochaines années
on veut pas faire plus parce que ça
coûte tellement c'est juste qu'on me l'a
plus rapidement pour le lit pis le plus
vite possible
notre sport deux pas des montagnes et
donc des parts de la nature donc on a
tout intérêt à préserver ses montagnes
l'oeil la nature environnement c'est ce
que la clientèle recherche donc on fait
les efforts quoi qu'il en soit ne se
fient demers estime que l'enneigement
artificiel devrait devenir un enjeu pris
davantage au sérieux quand on devrait
utiliser davantage le principe de
précaution en ce qui a trait à la
gestion de l'environnement de son côté
le ministère de l'environnement nous a
mentionné par courriel s'intéresser
actuellement à l'impact des changements
climatiques sur les quantités d'eau
disponibles
une réflexion qui pourrait avoir une
incidence sur l'autorisation de
prélèvement d'eau octroyés aux stations
de ski
ici thomas deshaies radio-canada offered